هل يمكنك أن تتخيل مدى حماسة جون عندما
عرضوا هذا الفيديو أريد أن أريكم إياه
الآن حيث التقطته
طائرة واحدة ورأوا في سماء الليل
تلك النقاط الثلاث الصغيرة هناك انظروا إليهم
إنهم يتحركون بشكل موسيقي
الطائرة التي  لقد رصدناهم وقالوا إننا لا
نعرف ما هو ذلك لقد حاولوا
مطاردته ولم يتمكنوا من مطاردته وتم
طرح هذا اليوم والآن
تنبيه المفسد درس علماء ناسا
هذا وفي النهاية قالوا
عندما جمعت كل الأدلة معًا
ماذا  كانت هذه ثلاث
طائرات تجارية في ممر طيران نموذجي،
والسبب في عدم تمكنهم من مطاردتهم
هو أنهم بعيدون كثيرًا
عما كانوا يعتقدون، وقد
أضاءوا ببساطة بهذه الطريقة، الحركة التي
ترونها هناك هي الطائرة التي تقلع
الصور عبر تلك المسافة ولهذا السبب
تبدو وكأنها تتحرك ذهابًا
وإيابًا، لذا فإن وجهة نظرهم هي القول بأن
هناك الكثير من الأشياء التي
يمكن تفسيرها في الواقع إذا كان بإمكانك الحصول على
معلومات كافية، فقد قالوا إن هناك
بعض الخصائص النموذجية التي تم الإبلاغ عنها
من uaps عندما تنظر إلى
كل هذه الأشياء هناك وكان هذا
مثيرًا للاهتمام نوعًا ما، وقد تم الإبلاغ عن هذا، وهذا
ما يقول الناس إنهم رأوه، ويقولون
عادةً إنهم مستديرون وصغيرون،
ويميلون إلى أن يكونوا فضيًا أبيض أو
شفافًا، ويميلون إلى أن يكونوا في مكان ما
بين  10 و30000 قدم في الهواء
إما ثابتة أو ما يصل إلى 2 ماخ أو
ضعف سرعة الصوت ولا يوجد
عادم حراري ولكن هنا تكمن المشكلة مع كل
ما قاله جون، المشكلة في ذلك هي أن هذا مجرد
قصص إلى حد كبير، فقط الناس
يقولون أن هذا ما رأوه  أو
يتم قياسه باستخدام جميع أنواع
الأدوات المختلفة والمجنونة،
وهذا هو المهم، هناك الكثير
من هذه التقارير، استمع إلى ما قيل
في هذا المؤتمر حول
الحجم الهائل لهذه التقارير الواردة
في وقت جلسة الاستماع المفتوحة  كنا
عند 650
حالة - لقد حصلنا على ما يقرب من ذلك، أعني أنه يمكنك
إجراء العمليات الحسابية التي تعلم أنها تعتمد في أي مكان
من 50 إلى
100 - أي تقارير جديدة شهريًا الآن،
والسبب وراء حصولنا على مثل هذه القفزة الكبيرة مؤخرًا هو أنني
حصلت على بيانات FAA  تم دمجها
أخيرًا وهكذا انتهى بنا الأمر بما يقرب من
100 وبعض الحالات الجديدة الغريبة، فالأرقام التي
أود أن أقول إننا نراها
ربما تكون شاذة حقًا هي أقل من
النسب المئوية المكونة من رقم واحد لتلك الحالات،
لذا فإن المشكلة الحقيقية هنا التي
تقولها ناسا هي ما نقوله حقًا  الحاجة هي خطة
للمضي قدمًا في طريقة
لأخذ هذا الكم الهائل من
المعلومات بشكل منهجي، كل تلك مقاطع الفيديو، كل تلك
التقارير، كل تلك الادعاءات وإخضاعها بطريقة أو بأخرى
لهذا النوع من
الدقة العلمية التي تشتهر بها ناسا وربما
سيتم شرح الكثير من هذا ولكن
من خلال كل هذا مرة أخرى، لا أحد
يقول على المستوى الحكومي أنهم
يعتقدون أن أيًا من هذا يأتي من الفضاء الخارجي
ربما أنظمة أسلحة متقدمة، ربما
أنظمة اتصالات أو سفر جديدة،
قد يكون بعضها مجرد ألغاز لكنهم لا
يعتقدون أنها كائنات فضائية